Speaker 1: this is one of the strangest
videos I have seen in a long time
in an absurd, absurd phone call. The story almost
slipped through the weekend kind of quietly,
but it's completely outrage. Outrageous. Donald
Trump had a phone call with professional golfer
John Daly. Now you might say why? Well, maybe
they were talking about golf, actually. They were
talking about foreign policy. Donald Trump was
on the phone with professional golfer John Daly,
and he talked about nuclear weapons and claimed
that he once threatened Putin with bombing Moscow.
That's the story. It it it makes no sense,
it's almost beyond belief, like what's what?
Why is Trump on the phone with daily? Why are
they talking about foreign policy? It's all
bizarre. And of course, if it's true that
Trump threatened Putin with bombing Moscow.
That's a fascinating story, too.
Let's take a listen to this.
This is Trump on speaker speaking to John
Daly, who increasingly looks like Glenn Beck,
interestingly enough. And listen
to what he had to say. Crazy stuff.
Speaker 3: Yeah, yeah. Nuclear
power. It's like friend. You know,
he was a friend of mine. I got along great
with him. Vladimir Putin visiting Moscow.
I said, We're going to get any sort
of believe me, like five percent,
10 percent. That's all you need.
He never did it during my campaign,
you know? No, no, he's funny. During
the last four years is Hillary Clinton.
It's funny how she didn't bother you, either.
Speaker 1: I like how he says, by the way, Chee.
Speaker 3: Yeah. No. She didn't want to be in
the heat. I told him the same thing you did.
That'll be next. Yeah. You know, that's going
to be next time. What will be next year? You
wouldn't have any computer chips that
would improve the face of the Earth.
Speaker 1: Now I actually agree with Trump.
There's a real possibility that China is
increasingly salivating over the idea of
doing something with Taiwan, given what's
going on in Ukraine right now with Russia. But
how wild is this? Trump told Putin he would hit
Moscow if it were this. This was previously
unknown in terms of our geopolitical relations
and foreign policy that Trump had threatened Putin
with bombing their capital city. I mean, I looked
and there's no record of that that I was able to
find. Now it's possible. Trump meant he told Putin
he wanted to hit the Moscow strip clubs that it
is possible that that's what Trump meant. We don't
want to rule it out. But I think he is talking
about bombing now. The other someone wrote to me
and said, David, is it possible? Trump thought he
was speaking with Jon Stewart from The Daily Show
instead of John Daley. Like, maybe that's the
explanation. And as funny as that is. I don't
think it really makes a difference because this
is still something we did not know Donald Trump
supposedly told Putin. But do we believe this?
Like Trump even said I was friends with Putin? I
don't know. I mean, is, is that even really true?
And this could be another one of these instances
of Trump wanting to be the alpha in front of
the pro athlete. It's all very, very strange.
But Trump very casually mentioning something to
a golfer that, if true, it's an incredible story.
That would be incredible if that is a foreign
policy discussion that took place. It's also silly
to talk about this with John Daley, because Daley
is an expert in Latin America, not in writing
anyway. That now, of course, it might just all be
a lie. Who knows? Why is Trump on the phone with
a golfer and saying these things? How do these
phone calls get scheduled in the first place?
Do you think it's a random call or what? What's
the backstory? It's bizarre. And one other note
some people are reacting as if Trump said,
I threatened Putin with nuking Moscow. It's
not at all clear from what Trump says that he's
talking about nukes now. It's true. Maybe he is,
I don't know. I don't think he's talking about
nuking Moscow. He's talking about bombing Moscow.
It's all crazy is the point and why Trump is
having these conversations with pro golfers
or former pro golfers. I genuinely don't know.
But it is another reminder that it's going to
take years for us to know the full scope of the
absurdity that was foreign policy under Trump.
If you're just listening today, we'll have this
clip on our Instagram, which you can find at David
Pakman show. And by the way, real quick, real
quick. I'm going to say more about this tomorrow.
We are launching a coaching initiative for
UP-AND-COMING podcasters, YouTubers and
content creators. We are accepting applications
at David Pakman dot com slash coaching. If you
are already a content creator, OK, that's
that. Now listen carefully to that. If you
were already a content creator with a YouTube
channel podcast or whatever, you can apply
for free coaching from me at David Pakman dot com
slash coaching. We're going to be doing a recorded
coaching sessions with a small,
curated group of creators.
The goal being to grow your platforms and your
shows and your content creation so you can apply
at David Pakman dot com slash coaching. It's a
very cool new thing. I'm super excited to do it
sort of like a giving back. I'm going to help
people after I was helped. You can apply at
David Pakman dot com slash coaching and I'll have
more information about that for you tomorrow.